Nikki Glaser. You have it all
The name of a professional porn
star
and the body or an amatuer porn
star.
You know I'm a big supporter of
the Me Too movement
but remember, Nikki. Me Too
shouldn't just be what a guy
says to his friend when he tells
him he had sex with Nikki Glaser
Noted.
There are so many celebrities
here tonight.
We have men from movies, women
from TV, and Lil Rel from
I'm guessing, the California
Raisins?
Oh, and now, the lovely Cybil
Shepard is here.
I remember years ago when I
heard there was going to be
a movie, a TV movie, about me, I
thought "Oh, God, no."
because they're always so
dreadful
I was really nervous. Well you
can imagine when relief when I
found out Cybil Shepard was
going to play me
I thought, Cybil Shepard? Great.
No one will see it.
No, Cybil. Isn't it interesting
that your career basically
ended after that roll?
as if you'd offended someone.
Someone with power
Someone with vast resources and
money.
Who could cook up such a plan?
Who could craft such a scheme?
I was me bitch.